poutine porte une attention particulière
à la france où se déroule au printemps
2010 est une élection présidentielle
décisive le favori emmanuel macron
candidat le moins favorable à moscou et
sont bien attaquer
les ordinateurs sont à quai des fakes
news relayée par les réseaux russe comme
celle d'un compte offshore
en pleine campagne électorale poutine
affiche son soutien à la candidate
d'extrême droite marine le pen en la
recevant durant une heure et demie c'est
la première fois que poutine prend aussi
ouvertement parti dans une élection
occidental
vous allez ben non c'est une petite
douleur là mais bon voilà vous est
empoisonnée coma
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les pensées du reportage sur m6 moi j'ai
trouvé très bien d'ailleurs je connais
je connais ce reportage je travaillais
avec enquête exclusive ils sont venus
chez moi à chamrousse et à faire des
interviews il ya trois ans je crois et
ligne de front de bernard de la
villardière c'est les journalistes qui
sont très sérieux qui accueilleront
le fois ça donc ouais ouais c'est c'est
pas moi et
donc moi j'ai pensé que ces deux c'est
une très très bonne enquête très
documentée trading retrait
dans des régions de différence sur les
questions des différentes et compris sur
la question de l'afrique qui
qu'on connaît un peu moins que l'ukraine
de laquelle on parle actuellement je te
rappelle tout à la pierre gentil et
merci d'être là sa vocation n'est pas du
tout apprécié le riz les reportages on
va dire mire poutine will it c'est
simple à vos yeux c'est hallucinant de
bêtises et c'est de la propagande et
même twitté c'est hallucinant de bêtises
propos péremptoires des témoignages
exclusivement à charge d'approximations
et d'omissions résumé poutine gros
méchant bourg un psychopathe occidentaux
non coupable oui c'est enfin oui ça vous
n'êtes pas d'accord est
très surprenant je ne sais pas mais puis
ça me surprend pas non plus que vous
soyez effectivement vous avez plus parce
que effectivement c'est un documentaire
qui est enfin c'est un si on veut se si
on veut comprendre que dans une guerre
de l'information alors oui il faut
regarder il faut regarder ce reportage
il faut regarder ce documentaire parce
que enfin je moi je les regarde et pour
tout vous dire j'ai perdu mon temps et
en même temps je me dis que ça servira
peut-être après pour pour des exemples
de ce qu'on veut faire comme propagande
occidentale parce que cas de la
propagande russe c'est une évidence mais
il ya aussi la propagande occidentale
c'est digne d'un dessin animé pour
enfant de 4 ans gers et du walt disney
c'est à dire 1 à poutine ce que je
disais gros méchant c'est poutine ne
crois qu'aux rapports de force les
américains n'ont les américains et c'est
un truc rapport au rapport de force et
la diplomatie des bisous que c'est bien
connu donc si vous les plénières poutine
c'est vraiment le méchant et de l'autre
côté les occidentaux bon il est 7 heures
d'effort il c'est de sauver les pauvres
pays qui sont agressés section attac et
autour il ya aucun rapport de force
économique autour il n'y a pas d'intérêt
non il ya une vision c'est celle d'un
poutine qui va envahir
tous les états baltes lucre je ne
conteste pas que l'ukraine que l'ukraine
sont enviées par poutine mais il ya
cette idée que il va reconstituer leur
père soviétique au bout c'est finalement
attaqué la france c'est quoi pour vous
c'est pas plus c'est pas aussi simple
que ça non c'est pas aussi simple c'est
difficile heures normalement là dans ce
genre de documentaire qui se présente
comme quelque chose de rationnel on
aurait pu en 1h30 essayé de présenter la
complexité des choses par exemple de
prese présenter la responsabilité
typiquement sur la férule craignent
haine des occidentaux si la faute est
évidemment la faute l'erreur alors de
vladimir poutine alors si c'est celle
d'envahir la russie explique qu'elle est
une raison politique sous la
responsabilité les occidentaux à
m'expliquer de la responsabiliser
occidentaux bas la première faillite et
occidentaux c'est de ne pas avoir
respecté le droit puisque même invité
aussi quand on vous dit c'est ben non
mais faut rattacher ça au droit des
accords avaient été conclus en guinée si
la danser en 2015 la s'agissant du sel
dessus de l'ukraine et en particulier
vous savez il ya eu une guerre civile en
ukraine on a un peu oublié parce qu'on
découvre une guerre mais je tiens juste
à rappeler à voter littérateurs ça fait
huit ans que sa guerre dure des morts
civiles puis il y en as dernier j'ai de
l'autre truc tu es d'accord et on a vécu
de sanctions contre la montre l'état
ukrainien parce que l'armée ukrainienne
a bombardé ses populations donc il ya
une guerre qui existait des accords qui
avaient été signés avec l'ukraine avec
la russie avec les occidentaux sur une
neutralisation au par une fédéralisation
de l'ukraine est progressivement une
pacification de ce territoire ça n'a pas
été respecté voilà maintenant on arrivé
à une extrémité je vous dis moi
évidemment je n'approuve pas l'invasion
de l'ukraine par la russie j'ai besoin
en tant que français je pense que ça va
déstabiliser l'europe mais les
occidentaux ont une responsabilité et ce
reportage précisément à fait totalement
l'impasse là dessus alors vous amis les
cinq extraits un à un les plus
importants pour nous on va passer au
troisième les méthodes de vladimir
poutine sont souvent extrêmes pour
gagner au plus vite la guerre en ukraine
il aurait là encore essayé de passer par
des moyens complètement fou c'est ce
qu'ils disent dans le reportage il
voudrait directement éliminé le
président ukrainien regarde
[Musique]
on l'entend le cuisinier du kremlin
evgeny prigogine
a déjà déployé ses mercenaires en syrie
en libye au venezuela au mali
aujourd'hui ils seraient arrivés par
centaines en ukraine les combattants de
wagner auraient été envoyés sur le
terrain avec une mission bien précise
traquer et tuer le président hélène ski
d'où viennent ces informations
de la division et la tour de la
télévision et de la division 2 quid la
télévision sur des rats contrairement à
envier aux et ils sont tellement larges
d'humour quand on n'a rien à dire non et
sont allés en
utilisant des sources et en dessin moi
je vais vous dire de oui oui des anglais
donc new york a qui sont en dehors des
américains et des ukrainiens donc
écouter on peut même pas vérifié ces
informations on est en est en guerre de
la proposer aux questions et on prend
ces informations nouvelles et comme
étant sûr je veux dire
pourquoi vous n'allez pas à moscou
invité à moscou
si je suis français mais si vous adorez
sit in j'ai hâte de voir mes seins voilà
non mais je vois franchement
heureusement des lecteurs et vous adorez
cynisme vous aurez pas dire qu'ils les
points qu'il nous ici ce n'est pas qu'un
arc j'adore depuis un mois oui on
regarde bombardent depuis sept mois la
menace depuis septembre l'année au
craignaient par des les russes l'armée
russe qui au dôme bamba l'armée russe a
est grosse a mixé l'armée russe oui à la
reprise de la guerre civile oui est ce
que vous allez plus 2014 les enquêtes de
complément d'enquêté poêler les équipes
de complément d'enquêté sont allés à 2 a
donné à lougansk y sont allés moi je les
connais ce baby g et dure aux personnes
qui sont allées la loi sans tarder et
l'armée russe ont ici un organe jugent
leur honneur c'est la toussaint qui aa
reconnu est ce l armée russe qui se bat
corps et il ya donc deux font de leur
faire aimer
c'est du terrorisme intellectuel s'il
vous plaît c'est l'un des principaux
opposants le son régime de vladimir
poutine s'appelle alexeï navalni san
avocat et militant politique qui a une
immense popularité en russie trop grande
aux yeux d'un hiver putsch mais ce
qu'ils nous disaient dans le
documentaire qui aurait voulu l'éliminer
regardez en tentant de l'empoisonner
[Musique]
on l'entend souffrir hurler de douleur
sur cette vidéo inconscient sur un
brancard l'un des principaux opposants à
vladimir poutine entre la vie et la mort
soigné dans un hôpital allemand y survit
miraculeusement alexeï navalni parvient
à piéger un membre du commando du fsb
chargé de l'empoisonner au bout de
plusieurs minutes de conversation alexeï
navalni obtient des confidences on avait
tout calculé avec une marge d'erreur
malgré l'évidence poutine nie toute
implication de l'état russe si on avait
voulu la faire aurait été menée à son
terme
alors simulé c'est ça c'est le seul gros
simuler quand en criant comme j'ai rien
dit pour l'instant malaisie par mais ok
non mais
vous n'avez pas compris une chose
chapelle avant l'heure il a passé
plusieurs mois dans le coma mais oui
d'accord très bien donc on doit envahir
la rue située poutine et puis bombardé
tout le pays c'est ça ce qu'il faut
faire pour essayer de raisonner 30
secondes monsieur que vlad qui utilise
des méthodes qui ne sont pas les
méthodes des occidentaux des moteurs non
démocratique
moi je raisonne en tant que français je
n'ai pas envie de me retrouver en guerre
avec la russie vous peut-être moins une
partie de l'association dialogue franco
russe pourtant tu as fait je suis membre
du bureau l'association de dialogue
franco russe absolument c'est un peu y
est toujours puisque je suis toujours
depuis 2004 ça existe depuis 2004
jacques chirac face à français et par
des rues 606 parc st-jacques non c'est
faux par chirac et par poutine ça a été
fondée en 2004 et effectivement je suis
membre de bureau du bureau du virus
depuis trois ans des maisons et demi
trois ans pour les poêles dialogue
franco russe et une association de droit
français 1920 d'accord mais voilà et qui
organise des conférences qui est cette
fois l'heure le rapprochement entre la
france et la russie même dans les
périodes difficiles alors je sais que
c'est compliqué entendre parce que quand
on entend ça on a l'impression que ça
veut dire vassalisation que ça veut dire
utilisation cette organisation elle a un
poids sur la russie ou pas du tout ah
ben non c'est vélin pas un poids sur la
russie non paiement elle s'adresse à une
association française la formation
française c'est plutôt essayer justement
de sensibiliser les français des
thématiques internationales de
géopolitique pour leur donner des clés
de lecture d'écriture peut-être
différent de celle qu'ont qu'on a
l'habitude d'entendre et je me réjouis
que cette situation continue à faire son
travail si vous avez des infos je crois
oui là où je suis d'accord avec vous et
je ne suis pas d'accord avec sergei
c'est au niveau des reportages télé je
les trouve très à charge et moi c'est
rien il ya quelque chose qui me gêne on
a l'impression quand même que dans ses
reportages là on réécrit l'histoire
comme si on savait alors on présente
poutine comme le diable le démon mais si
on le savait pourquoi on fait maintenant
pour qu'on la patte avant enfin de son
orient tout à l'aune de ce qui s'est
passé et ça c'est une faiblesse énorme
ego lui et moi mais si les
emprisonnements par exemple si vous le
saviez le nombre de
nos vies tout le monde me tournait les
saloperies mais
tout le monde glissait il
ya les ont
mené les enquêtes les anglais ont mené
les enquêtes en dessous j'avais comme ça
en france mais non
c'est quand même bien la france et
l'allemagne qui ont sauvé navalni paris
ont permis de
discuter je
le rejoins mais qui sont quand même
orienté et pour qu'on les a pas fait
avant en fait on réécrit l'histoire ma
peau présent au meeting comme un démon
nous sommes tous bossé depuis que
j'avais accès que que poutine et de
propagande heure française
pour les rues saint germain et là c'est
pareil honnêtement je vois pas je vois
poutine s'est passé quand même pas cessé
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai danger
ça fait 15 ans qu'on cesse été faites
ont été faites on a engrangé qu'on a
chez un monsieur âgé pas excusez moi
en ukraine d'accord mais d'accord
sur la gueule je sais c'est pas
dangereux c'est parce qu'il a dit non
dit qui alors on essaie système de
défense nucléaire
en fait valoir propagande soviétique
n'existe
pas même chose on va voir un dernier
extrait alors qu'il est arrêté à son
retour en russie on a parlé de alex et
en albanie il ya un instant un des
principaux opposants russes ont rugi
régime de vladimir poutine une enquête
il a fait une enquête il a publié où il
rêvait d'une partie de la fortune de
vladimir poutine il parle notamment
d'une maison regardez quelle somme
pourrait valoir la maison
poutine s'est fait construire cette
immense palais de 17 mille mètres carrés
sur les rives de la mer noire coût
estimé de ce projet mégalomaniaque plus
d'un milliard de roubles c'est le
symbole des vingt années de règne de
poutine s'ils lèvent le symbole des lois
répressives et du vol des pauvres s'ils
venaient à petit de toutes les
incarcérations et tout ça pour quoi pour
de l'or et du marbre mais le résultat
est finalement de très mauvais goût tout
cela traduit une vie de petite envergure
extrêmement minuscule en fait il veut se
prouver à lui même et aux autres qu'il
est un grand personnage historique
alors
déjà par rapport à ces documentaires par
exemple ça c'est très documenté il ya
une très très grande enquête qui a été
menée avec lennon avec les pros la
proviseure devra la provenance des fonds
le le terrain appartient au fsb le
terrain et gardé par les forces de la
protection de la présidence de russie si
c'est pas poutine pourquoi elle le
protège à l'autre chose aussi ce
documentaire qu'on a un qu'on a vue sur
la vie sur m6 et l'autre sur sur sur
l'a5 ces deux documentaires face à ça
vous aviez rachat tous des scouts nick
qui pendant vingt ans pendant 20 ans
français ont bombardé le public français
avec la propagande de russie depuis six
ans d'opale en temps non valverde 29 ans
rts que
n'existent pas partout des ailes et ria
novosti existait avant spoutnik et avant
rachète ou des guerriers massaï ça
existait depuis 20 ans et même d'un du
tour d'une union soviétique voilà et
donc pour compenser ça peut-être ce
documentaire ok ils ne regardent que le
côté négatif mais ce ne coter négatif il
va peut-être prendre compenser juste un
tout petit peu c'est propagande de
poutinienne qui est là depuis plusieurs
années merci sergei voulais rajouter
quelque chose oui oui tout à fait c'est
à dire que j'ai vu ces images et c'est
vrai que on est d'accord c'est la
résidence secondaire du président de la
fédération de russie ça on a filmé fait
alors j'aimerais féliciter j'en ai ce
qu'en fait ça parce que c'est vrai que
pour une zone une équipe journalistes
étrangers arrivés à mettre un drone qui
survole la résidence du président de la
république de russie elle doit être très
mal surveillées donc j'espère que le les
services de renseignement russes ont vu
le reportage et vont hélas on a roulé en
avant juste une boîte de castagne
vu pour une chose après déterminé c'est
vrai quoi encore une fois c'est ce qu'on
disait avant ce que vous disiez je vais
garder ce jour joint c'est à dire que
pourquoi ça arrive maintenant pourquoi
est ce qu'on parle de ça maintenant sans
doute peut-être oui bah écoutez ça
existe mais je veux dire en tant que
français enfin écoutez ce qui fait ça
regarde ça regarde son pays ça regarde
ses habitants
attendent et on fait quoi en fait ma
question c'est quoi si on fait quoi donc
comme ça la demi-heure footing puis de
l'argent un milliard ne faut pas aider
le crir tu fais quoi
mais justement c'est très intéressant
pourquoi vous dites ça vous voyez ça à
l'ukraine a donc ça veut bien dire que
ce reportage vous voyez est fait pour
nous aiguiller sur des positions non
parce qu'il y en a son lien et enghien
non nous sommes dans une ère de
décrypter un incident dont je mexique et
dans le monde si ça tout seul
merci merci les chéris